Déjenme mostrarles algunas imágenes
de lo que yo considero serán las ciudades del mañana.
Esa es Kibera, la comuna más grande en Nairobi.
Esta es la comuna en el parque nacional Sanjay Gandhi
en Bombay, India, ahora llamada Mumbai.
Esta es Hosinia, la favela más grande y urbanizada
en Rio de Janeiro.
Y esta es Sultanbelyi,
la cual es una de las comunas más grandes en Estanbul.
Estas son lo que yo considero serán las ciudades del mañana,
el nuevo mundo urbano.
Ahora, porque digo esto?
Para contarles eso tengo que hablarles de este otro compañero,
su nombre es Julius.
Y yo conocí a Julius la ultima semana que estuve viviendo en Kibera.
Yo llevaba casi tres meses ahí,
y estaba dando un tour por la ciudad, visitando distintas áreas asentadas
y Julius me seguía, y estaba muy sorprendido
y en ciertos puntos mientras caminábamos,
el sostenía mi mano para apoyarse,
algo que la mayoría de las personas de Kenya nunca considerarían hacer.
Ellos son muy amables y no son tan atrevidos tan rápido.
Después descubrí que este era el primer día de Julius en Nairobi,
y el es uno de muchos.
Así, que cerca de 200,000 personas al día
migran desde las áreas rurales hacia las urbanas.
Y voy a ser justo con los estadistas
que hablaron esta mañana, no son casi 1.5 millones de personas por semana,
pero si casi 1.4 millones de personas por semana; pero yo soy un periodista,
y nosotros exageramos, así que son casi 1.5 millones por semana,
cercano a 70 millones de personas al año.
Y si hacemos la matemática, son 130 personas cada minuto.
Así, que seria -- en los 18 minutos que me dan para esta charla,
entre 2 y 3,000 personas han de haber viajado a las ciudades.
Y estas son las estadísticas.
Hoy --mil millones de ocupantes,
uno de seis personas en el planeta.
2030 -- dos mil millones de asentados ilegales,
uno de cada cuatro personas en el planeta.
Y el estimado es que en el año 2050, serán tres mil millones de ocupantes.
mas de uno de cada tres personas en la tierra.
Así, que estas son las ciudades del futuro, y tenemos que involucrarnos con ellas.
Y yo estaba pensando esta mañana acerca de la buena vida,
y antes que les muestre el resto de mi presentación,
Voy a violar las reglas de TED aqui,
y voy a leerles algo de mi libro tan rápido como me sea posible.
Porque yo creo que dice algo acerca de cambiar nuestra percepción
de lo que nosotros pensamos es la buena vida.
Entonces -- "La choza esta hecha de metal corrugado, fijada a una cama de concreto.
Esta era un celda de 10 por 10.
Armstrong O'Brian Jr. la compartía con otros tres hombres.
Armstrong y sus amigos no tenían agua,
ellos la compraban de una persona cercana que tenia agua del grifo.
No había baño, las familias en esta comuna compartían una letrina de un solo pozo.
y no habían alcantarillas o servicio de sanidad.
Ellos tenían electricidad,
pero era un servicio ilegal conectado a los cables de otra persona,
y nada mas podía dar energía para a un débil bombillo.
Esta era Southland, una comunidad pequeña y pobre
en la parte oeste de Nairobi, Kenya.
Pero pudo haber sido cualquier parte de la ciudad,
porque mas de la mitad de la ciudad de Nairobi es así.
1.5 millones de personas apretadas en las chozas de barro o metal.
sin servicios, o baños, o derechos.
Armstrong explicó la brutal realidad de su situación,
ellos pagan 1,500 chelines en arriendo, como 20 dolares al mes,
un precio relativamente alto para un pueblo pobre en Kenya,
y ellos no podían tomar el riesgo de demorarse con el dinero.
'En caso que uno deba un mes, el propietario llegaría con sus secuaces
y te sacarían. El confiscaría tus cosas, 'dijo Armstrong.
'No un mes, un día,' habló su compañera de habitación Hilary Kibagendi Onsomu,
que cocinaba ugali, una mezcla de harina de maíz blanca esponjosa
que es un alimento básico en el país, interviniendo en la conversación.
Ellos llamaban a su propietario un Wabenzi, queriendo decir que es una persona
que tiene suficiente dinero para manejar un Mercedes-Benz.
Hilary sirvió el ugali con una fritura de carne y tomates,
el sol golpeaba el delgado techo de acero,
y sudamos mientras comimos.
Después que terminamos, Armstrong enderezó su corbata,
se puso una chaqueta deportiva de lana, y salimos de frente al brillo.
Afuera una monte de basura formaba la frontera
entre Southland y el barrio legal adjunto de Langata.
Tenia tal vez ocho piea (2.5m) de altura, 40 pies (10m) de largo, y 10 pies (3m) de ancho.
Y estaba localizado en un ancho exudado acuoso.
Mientras pasábamos dos niños estaban escalando el monte Kenya de basura.
Ellos tendrían no mas de cinco o seis años de edad.
Estaban descalzos, y cada paso sus dedos se hundían en la porquería
desplazando cientos de moscas de la rancia pila.
Pensé que ellos podrían estar jugando al Rey de la Loma, pero estaba equivocado.
Una vez en la cima de la pila, uno de los niños bajo sus pantalones cortos,
se agacho, y defeco.
Las moscas zumbaron ansiosamente alrededor de sus piernas.
Cuando veinte familias --100 personas mas o menos -- comparten una sola letrina,
un niño haciendo popo en una pila de basura no es gran cosa tal vez .
Pero resaltaba en un discordante contraste
a algo que Armstrong había dicho mientras comimos --
que el valoraba la calidad de vida de su barrio.
Para Armstrong, Southland no estaba limitado por sus condiciones materiales.
En cambio, el espíritu humano irradiaba
de las paredes metálicas y los montones de basura para ofrecer algo
que ningún barrio legal podía -- libertad.
'Este lugar es muy adictivo,' el había dicho.
'Es una vida simple, pero nadie te esta restringiendo.
Nadie esta controlando lo que tu haces.
Una vez te has quedado aquí, ya no puedes regresar.'
El quiso decir regresar, mas allá de la montaña de basura,
regresar a la ciudad legal, a los edificios legales,
con derechos y arrendamientos legales.
'Una vez que te has quedado aquí,' dijo el,
puedes quedarte por el resto de tu vida.'"
Así, que el tiene esperanza, y así es que estas comunidades comienzan.
Este es tal vez el barrio mas primitivo que alguien pueda encontrar en Kibera,
un poco mas que una choza de palos y barro junto a una pila de basura.
Esto es la preparación para un monzón en Bombay, India.
Estas son mejoras para el hogar.
Poner lonas de plástico en tu techo.
Esto es Rió de Janeiro, y se esta poniendo un poco mejor, verdad?
Estamos viendo escavados de loza terracota y pequeños pedazos de señalamientos,
y yeso sobre ladrillo, algo de color,
y esto es la casa de Sulay Montakaya en Sultanbelyi, y se va mejorando.
El tiene una cerca, y ha hurgado una puerta de la basura.
Tiene nuevas tejas en el techo.
Y después te tienes Rocinha
y puedes ver que se va mejorando.
Los edificios aquí tienen múltiples pisos.
Se desarrollan -- puede verse en el extremo derecho.
uno donde parece que se apilan unos encima del otro
habitación, tras habitación, tras habitación.
Y lo que hace la gente es construir sus propios hogares en uno o dos pisos,
y ellos venden su logia o derechos de techo,
y alguien mas construye encima de su edificio,
y después esa persona vende los derechos de techo,
y alguien mas construye encima de ese edificio.
Todos estos edificios están hechos de concreto reforzado y ladrillo.
Y después uno llega a Sultanbely, en Turquía, donde se construye
a un nivel de diseño mas alto.
El crudo en el frente es relleno de colchón,
y uno puede ver esto por toda Turquía.
La gente seca o airea su relleno de colchón en sus techos.
Pero el edificio verde, detrás,
uno puede ver que el piso superior no esta ocupado,
así que la gente esta construyendo con la posibilidad de expansión.
Y esta construido a un estándar de diseño bastante alto.
Y después, cuando finalmente tienes casas de comuna como esta,
que están construidos en un modelo suburbano.
Ey, esto es un hogar de una familia en una comuna.
Esto también esta en Estanbul, Turquía.
Estas comunidades, son lugares bastante vitales.
Ese es el mayor estrecho de Rocinha, la Estrada da Gavea,
y hay una ruta de autobús, que corre por ella,
mucha gente esta en las calles.
Las comunidades en estas ciudades son verdaderamente mas vitales
que las comunidades legales.
Hay mas cosas sucediendo en ellas.
Este es un camino típico en Rocinha, llamado un beco --
de esta manera es como uno se mueve en la comunidad.
Esta en terreno muy inclinado.
Están construidos en las lomas, tierra adentro de las playas de Rio,
y uno puede ver que las casas están sostenidas a forma de balcón sobre obstrucciones naturales.
Asi, eso es solamente una roca en la ladera.
Y los becos están normalmente muy atestados,
y la gente les encima muebles, o refrigeradores,
todo tipo de cosas.
Toda la cerveza es acarreada sobre hombros.
La cerveza es algo muy importante en Brasil.
Esto es comercio en Kenya, justo a lo largo de la vía del tren,
tan cerca a la vía del tren que los comerciantes
algunas veces tienen que sacar su mercancía fuera del camino.
Este es un mercado, también en Kenya, El Mercado Toi,
muchos negociantes, en casi todo lo que quiera uno comprar.
Esas cosas verdes en el primer plano son mangos.
Esta es un calle de compras en Kibera,
y uno puede ver que hay un vendedor de bebidas gaseosas, una clínica de salud,
dos salones de belleza, un bar, dos tiendas de mercado, una iglesia, y mucho mas.
Esta es una calle típica del centro, parece ser estar auto-construida.
Esto aquí, a del lado derecho,
es lo que se le llama -- si ves la letra pequeña debajo del toldo --
es un hotel.
Y lo que un hotel significa, en Kenya y en India, es un lugar para comer.
Así, que esto es un restaurante.
La gente roba la energía eléctrica -- este es Río.
La gente se aprovecha y tienen ladrones que les llaman grillos,
y ellos roban la energía eléctrica,
y conectan todo el barrio.
La gente quema desperdicios para deshacerse de la basura,
y ellos excavan sus propios canales de alcantarillado.
Hablando mas de bolsas de plástico que de plancton,
y a veces ellos tienen eliminación natural de desechos.
Y cuando tienen mas dinero ellos pavimentan sus calles,
y ponen alcantarillas y buenas tuberías de agua, y cosas por el estilo.
Esta es agua yendo a Río, la gente tiene sus tuberías de agua por todo lado,
y esa pequeña choza ahí tiene una bomba, y eso es lo que la gente usa.
Roban electricidad, instalan una bomba
e interceptan la tubería principal, y bombean agua hacia sus casas.
Así que, la pregunta es, como se va de una villa de chozas de barro,
a una ciudad desarrollada, hasta incluso, el altamente desarrollado Sultanbelyi?
Yo digo que hay dos cosas.
Una es que estas personas necesitan la garantía que no serán desalojados.
Eso no significa necesariamente derechos de propiedad,
y yo estaría en desacuerdo con Hernando Soto en este punto,
porque los derechos de propiedad traen muchas complicaciones,
son frecuentemente vendidos a personas, y las personas después terminan en deuda
y tienen que pagar esta deuda,
y algunas veces tienen que vender su propiedad
para poder pagar esta deuda.
Existe otra variedad de razones por las cuales los derechos de propiedad
algunas veces no funcionan en estos casos,
pero ellos si necesitan seguridad de permanencia.
Y necesitan acceso a la política, y eso puede significar dos cosas.
Eso puede significar una comunidad organizándose desde abajo,
pero también puede significar posibilidades desde arriba.
Y digo esto porque el sistema en Turquía es sobresaliente.
Turquía tiene dos de las mejores leyes para la protección de comunas.
Una es -- se llama gecekondu en Turco,
que quiere decir construido de la noche a la mañana, y si uno construye su casa de la noche a la mañana
en Turquía, uno no puede ser desalojado sin un proceso legal apropiado,
si eres es descubierto durante la noche.
Y el segundo aspecto es que una vez tienes 2,000 personas
en la comunidad, uno puede solicitar al gobierno
para ser reconocido como una sub-municipalidad legal.
Y cuando uno es una sub-municipalidad legal, uno de repente tiene política.
Se te permite tener un gobierno electo, cobrar impuestos,
proveer servicios municipales, y eso es exactamente lo que ellos hacen.
Así, que estos son los lideres cívicos del futuro.
La mujer en el centro de Geeta Jiwa.
Ella vive en una de esas chozas en la autopista mediana en Mumbai.
Esta es Sureka Gundi, ella también vive con su familia
en una choza al lado de la misma mediana de la autopista.
Ellas son muy francas. Ellas son muy activas.
Ellas pueden ser lideres comunitarios.
Esta mujer es Nine, que significa abuela en Turco.
y habían tres mujeres de edad que vivían en --
esta es su casa construida por ella detrás de ella -- y ellas viven ahí por 30 o 40 años,
y ellas son la columna vertebral de la comunidad en este lugar.
Este es Richard Muthama Peter,
y el es un fotógrafo callejero ambulante en Kibera.
El gana dinero tomando fotos del barrio,
y de las personas en el barrio
y es un gran recurso para la comunidad.
Y finalmente mi elección para que correr por la alcaldía de Rió es Cezinio,
el comerciante de fruta con sus dos hijos aquí,
y una persona mas honesta y caritativa no he conocido.
El futuro de estas comunidades son la gente
y nuestra habilidad de trabajar con esta gente.
Así, que yo pienso que el mensaje que tomo, de lo que leí del libro,
de lo que Armstrong dijo, y de toda esta gente,
es que estos son barrios.
El asunto no es pobreza urbana.
El asunto no la cosa de mas largo alcance.
El asunto es que nosotros reconozcamos que estos son barrios.
Esta es una forma legitima de desarrollo urbano,
y que las ciudades tienen que involucrar a estos residentes,
porque ellos están construyendo las ciudades del futuro.
Muchas gracias.